hello everyone welcome to the Internet
my name is troika this is a Facebook
live session live from the set of thor
ragnarok look look at this cool set this
is just a lake or practical we didn't
make it I'm just lying but
[Music]
hello ha so welcome welcome I'm gonna
take you for a little walk
sorry about the shakiness so nervous
introduce some of the crew and a few
people around here and show you some of
the stuff we've been building down here
this here is a kind of sci-fi space
wasteland a space land a space to land
the building and this oh by the way this
is our last day of shooting so you know
we've really come to the end of the
journey we've come to the end of the
experience I had a great time made some
nice new friends and you can't believe
84 days 84 days later so here's some of
the some of the crew here yeah you had a
real good day from a real Australian
shaking it and one thing you know about
you notice that film sets they're loud
it's just noise all day long look like
they're just cranes as equipment we're
actually in this beautiful little lake
area just outside of the Gold Coast and
would you know it you would you're not
sure if you believe this but that little
hole thing over there it's full of
snakes
full of snakes and the water is full of
platypus that's a bar a whatever the
plural of pleasure piece is hi guys he's
me coming through
it's alright don't be sorry strangers
are so polite they were sorry for
everything sorry for living sorry for
existing they're not sorry thing they
say well this gene is Jennifer my
Mikhail Mikhaylovich James taking these
guys for a walk love much love come with
me look yeah I told them who Lynn my
name for the Facebook life things
scrappers these guys going the extra
mile they've been gone the extra mile
and yeah they dress themselves up and
all these hot cars hot blazing blazing
hot Australian heat yeah so those are
the real heroes not those other idiots
like Chris Hemsworth and yes sir
Thompson and stuff oh wait what hello
Internet
it's justice of information highway like
a highway but full of information its
new its new has just come out
how is everybody good what kind he is
I'm on the sound
I can't hear everybody's but we can hear
all the typing this is isn't it Chris
Christ the crossbars imlah spelling
well i'ma go for a walk
sure okay thank you Suns on such a crazy
angle that Oh on a selfie stick
walking naturally walking up just being
natural everyone's acting that true I
just talked about how this was the one
of the most terrible experiences of my
life
well we would say the same thing you
guys now that we've gotten rid of you it
should be alright yeah well this is my
last hour I'm getting fired after the
space I think we're all getting fired
today yes available on VHS
yeah if this movie's going straight to
VHS yeah and there's only gonna be one
copy though so you left to share it
around
rentals I think are about 50 bucks yeah
school school playground rental system
yeah that's where Netflix exists I'm
actually originated yeah one copy of a
movie and you'd pass it around a threat
yeah and everyone wants to see it so
probably get together with a few friends
and watch it all at once sometime yeah
let's go and have a look at these these
people up here people everywhere I don't
know what anyone does and now this is
gonna be the embarrassing part where I
say hey look look who it is and I don't
remember anyone's name for 18 weeks I
can say my name
yeah actually Daniel yeah it's doing
good everyone sorry
[Music]
that was everyone I'm just gonna go look
at them all just natural that's so
friendly there's naturally friendly
people here in Australia any secret I
know what things I'm allowed to show or
not stunt man extraordinary Bharat Bobby
handsome is um Krista's Chris a stunt
double all the stunts and all the
kissing scenes yeah do you guys get to
kiss you too sir I'm not gonna try and
just my camera rates pretty so
sorry sorry what what else okay here we
go look here's producer of this film hi
world yeah hey world say hello back to
bread this here is our exclusive
Ragnarok emblem which we revealed what
that thing actually is soon yes Brian
branch epic we love you take it ah this
isn't all about me I didn't tell you
guys to say it's just naturally
happening
it's the priest from other people we
love you making comments like we just
want a secret something back the other
way okay so that's pretty much it wasn't
too impossible to see what we were
trying to show you today hello did I
just do my hair makeup the morning by my
selfie stick
[Music]
slowly Tesla will have to go to makeup
to get here face tattoos covered up best
of all and she got this actually
tattooed on your face apparently saying
we can't say anything about where we are
and you're not allowed to tell you on
what you've seen so well just an awesome
this awesomeness that is people asking
questions hi Chris
hi Lorna Daly and all this 2500 comments
we've got it's really quick let's scroll
all the way to the top and just yeah Tom
Hiddleston is start an account called
Bella McCoy and he's written loki where
are you you're my favorite can't wait to
see the movie thank you to do this
silly remedy please listen sister brick
it's like a brick but it's breakable for
those of you who've seen stunt guys
these guys who put their lives on the
line every day and then they come to
work and sit around doing nothing
[Music]
amazing and taking it inside the
spaceship yeah there's a few weapons
crash probably just like a crutch all
right well believe it or not we probably
actually should go back to work and
finish making this movie otherwise no
one's ever gonna see it
it's our last day I'm not gonna say it
sorry yet could we stalk you hours to go
but it's nearly a wrap and I love all of
these people who are here and we've had
an amazing time with them I'm gonna take
you down DP is making these beautiful
pictures
[Music]
oh my god this has come through delay
I'm filming a live Facebook live session
not ever done that this inception okay
okay is time
to say goodbye oh I can't do it over
okay jump in guys come close thanks for
tuning in to this weird thing that we
just did hope you enjoyed the extreme of
the interesting things we're talking
about all the secrets but we divulge
amazing props like that fella starring
brick that you saw this has been a real
cool experience for ya see film was
finally finished on VHS 2025 see ya bye
oh I'm ending on that these t-shirts
coming out by the way soon you can get
one on there holding a little for a
little bit of role reversal there as we
call it on set and the Rainbow Bridge
gets rather sunny and bright sir
sunglasses and for next correct spelling
is mill name pronounced Joel Nick Joan
are yep see you later
and now I just know how to turn this off
stop how do we finish okay